alors autre sujet polémique maintenant
en pleine mobilisation des jeunes est
jeune on va parler des rémunérations et
des avantages des hommes politiques qui
sont vivement critiquées remise en cause
c'est le cas notamment de ceux des
anciens présidents de la république qui
bénéficient de privilèges assez
conséquent soit bien le dire bodeur
direct nous en dit plus et nous on en
parle juste après prenons le cas d'un
ancien président au hasard françois
hollande
il est peut-être en compte se lever pour
rejoindre ses bureaux rue de rivoli plus
de 300 mètres carrés payés et meublée
par l'état comme pour tous les anciens
présidents
il s'apprête à dire bonjour deux
policiers qui assurent sa protection et
à ses sept collaborateurs permanents qui
seront réduits à 3-5 ans après la fin de
son mandat un petit coup d'oeil aux
journaux les abonnements sont offertes
pour valéry giscard d'estaing c'est
l'abonnement coûte 800 euros par mois
alors pour les avantages des
ex-présidents on l'a vue là le
traitement indiciaire ses 6000 220 euros
bruts mensuels et son membre à vie du
conseil constitutionnel ce qui
représente à 14000 euros brut mensuel
ils ont des locaux meublés et équipés
avec deux employés à disposition sept
collaborateurs permanents deux agents de
service la protection rapprochée
qu'est ce que vous en penser ce qu après
tout c'est normal ils ont donné de leur
personne pour la nation ils peuvent être
également en danger parce que on peuvent
être la cible d'attentats ou autre ou
est ce que vous dites après tout quand
ils ont fini leur job
ils ont fini leur job ils peuvent passer
à autre chose mais on donne tous de
notre personne vous donner toute
personne à le faire sans la verdure à
des colloques exactement et pourquoi pas
aussi dans ces cas-là nom met en avant
guingamp
enfin je veux dire jusqu'à la fin de ma
poule en voiture simone on va falloir
aller très bien
c'est totalement abusé moi je veux bien
qu'ils aient une protection
voilà autour de la personne faut quand
même savoir que quand c'est président
qui sont tous quand même doué enfin
intellectuellement d'une certaine
manière quand ils sortent de leurs de
leurs fonctions à présidentielle ils
facturent ce formidable la journée pour
faire une conférence à washington avait
notamment pour tous les américains qui
n'ont jamais donné la leçon aux ondes
n'auront jamais de problèmes économiques
ils n'auront on nous dit de faire des
économies partout ce qui est justifié
c'est la protection rapprochée parce
qu'effectivement on sait jamais ce qu'il
peut il est tout ce qui nous reste et
annexes et donc superflu j'étais remet
alors écoute tu fasses quoi ils vont pas
devenir caissier au au supermarché du
coin quand tu t'appelles nicolas serait
pas
trois maisons hollande qui tapotaient
scène ce que ça pourrait être très très
drôle j'irai acheter mais croissante
chez profond autre chose ils font des
conférences dans les dom alors beaucoup
moins que les américains aient payé une
tonne beaucoup moins que les américains
c'est l'heure pour ça que les américains
coûte vachement moins cher aux
contribuables américains écoutent
pratiquement un tiers de ce que coûte à
un français parce que les américains
pour le coup ils se sortent les doigts
et ils vont faire des conférences dont
les précédentes pour ça wayne rooney
d'accord rodez est effectivement aux
états unis n'ont pas de soucis à énoncer
l'argent qu'il gagne par oui là-bas
c'est bien vu aussi voile et à la rame
en fait mais moi ça ne me choque pas du
tout parce que le président de la
république voilà ce n'est pas le serveur
du bistrot du coin même si évidemment je
respecte tous les serveurs de tous les
bistrots criardes et twitter meba c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait de très longues
études qui a eu encore je me fais un peu
l'avocat du diable mais est ce qu'il est
nécessaire que l'on paye les 800 euros
d'abonnement à tous les quotidiens alors
qu'on sait qu'on peut les avoir à 9
euros par mois
alors après effectivement faut peut-être
moderniser aussi la façon dont ils
lisent la presse mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est qu'en plus les rires
président de la république ne restent
pas inactifs après leur mandat c'est à
dire que par exemple valéry giscard
d'estaing siéger au conseil
constitutionnel il ya également jacques
chirac qui a créé sa fondation en faveur
de la paix enfin c'est des personnes
confinant certes mais pour aussi parfois
la bonne cause
dimanche vous ai pas entendu c'est vrai
qu'on veut peut-être un peu pondéré il
ya peut-être des économies à faire mais
ça reste trois quatre cinq personnes
dans le monde finalement fin dans l'aude
en offrant des enfants et je pense que
effectivement on est dans une situation
où on veut de l'excellent parité on veut
de la transparence
on veut que le train de vie de l'état ça
diminue et je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faut
focaliser simplement sur sa même si les
sommes sont extraordinaires ils ont été
au plus haut sommet de l'état vous c'est
pas là qu'il faut faire les économies à
une cheville et d'ailleurs on peut faire
un petit quelque chose mais quand il
faut respecter le fait qu'ils étaient
président qu'ils ont droit à une
rémunération malgré tout qu'il faut
qu'ils aient du personnel c'est pas
n'importe qui attaquons-nous au budget
de l'état ou train de vie d'autres
députés d'autres ministres je pense
qu'on aura beaucoup de surprises
après les alains qui va nous coûter
quand même assez cher parce que je vous
rappelle qu emmanuel macron il ya 40 ans
du coup l'année mais faire d'accor le
président de la république est ce que
c'est normal ou est-ce qu'il faut les
supprimer je vous nous avez dit qu'il
faut les supprimer à 91% c'est un raz de
marée